[Music]
it can be hard to get a perspective on a
presidency of the unpredictable a year
after the heady haze of Donald Trump's
victory the political landscape in
America is etched with enthusiasm and
indignation but in the furnaces
factories and foothills of Utah
something more subtle that explains his
enduring appeal Utah has a complicated
relationship with Donald Trump
politically it's broadly aligned with
him and his pro-business message has
gone down very well but morally this
deeply religious state has often been at
odds with him uncomfortable with some of
his language and behavior after a
presidential race played out in
technicolor the feelings towards
America's leader here and in so much of
the country just aren't black and white
[Music]
[Music]
Donald Trump brought a megaphone to
Washington kicking off with tough talk
on immigration we could have a very very
pretty and and we're going to have
extreme vetting the Supreme Court
secured a more lasting legacy from
hiring to an explosive firing that
reignited the Russia investigation
tonight I ordered a targeted military
strike on the airfield the new approach
to America's friends and enemies
Rocketman is on a suicide mission for
himself
one thing the administration can and
will keep coming back to the economy
jobs jobs jobs jobs
you can hear the optimism at the top of
my tea light a global manufacturer of
furniture south of Salt Lake City his
first year in office a stock market
higher it's ever been the economy's very
strong as I say unemployment's as low as
it's ever been and whether you want to
attribute it directly to him or not the
fact of the matter is that after a year
in office and all the turmoil
surrounding it the economy still remains
a strong a stronger that's ever been so
he has to get some credit for that the
president can lay claim to the most
substantive change to u.s. tax law in 16
years the kind of massive corporate cut
Republicans have been after for decades
on the factory floor hope and what do
you make of what you've seen from Donald
Trump so far so far I have enjoyed and
I'm pleased to see what he's done the
tax plan for 2018 it's going to be very
beneficial to my family so I'm pleased
to see that it's happened I just he just
seems like he wants to go to war with
everyone he when he wants to tweet and
getting these little Twitter feuds with
everybody instead of focusing on his job
as running our country it saddens me
that there's so many Democrats and so
many people that are trying to tear him
apart and he's done a lot of good things
and a lot of things are not even
televised that he's doing
there may be more for billionaires to
capture than low-paid america but
they're both expected to feel some
benefit Utah is known as the Beehive
State because its people are so
industrious and some of them can see
early echoes of their own success in the
president's push on construction
manufacturing and mining if you look
from a broad perspective of where the
president has has wanted to go and where
he's been working with Congress the
policies and the strategy is is where
you toss probably been going for
generations we've headed down the
direction of being aggressive as a state
in terms of being open to business to
allowing the state to let the private
sector drive the economy grow the
economy produce jobs hire more
individuals pay more wages produce more
taxes and I think the president's vision
mirrors that
[Music]
you have to look deeper though progress
is a game of perception and us synthetic
an industrial diamond drill manufacturer
live it every day so in this environment
where oil price is a little bit higher
it's a little more
we're able to take advantage of those
opportunities without going
[Music]
but here's the rub they get some of
their vital components from South Korea
and the president's war of words with
Pyongyang has cost them we have critical
materials that come from that part of
the world
and so when we feel like there's a
little bit of geopolitical instability
in that part of the world we have to
stockpile some of that material to
buffer that risk that means that the
dollars that we would normally put into
other investments go into stockpiling
some material are you doing that more in
the past year then you have in previous
years yes absolutely
and in a state built by religious exile
people are uneasy about the immigration
crackdown I feel like a lot of the
programs that Obama's brought up for
kids that you know for these types of
individuals you know end up being ripped
away from them it's affecting a lot of
us who earned credit bought cars buy
homes fill their lives have kids
[Music]
you can see a telling trade-off here
Utah is 60% Mormon a church that is
pro-life and anti gay marriage many of
its followers have kept faith in the
Republican agenda even if at a funeral
for their prophet there is discomfort
about Donald Trump's conduct and
rhetoric I think we would do better to
have someone with I don't know better
morals I know he's a little bit brash a
little bit brazen sometimes but he I
think he has a good heart and he means
well leading the nation I just hope that
he can really fulfill his purpose in
unifying the nation and you know I I
pray for him and that I recognize him as
a leader a strong leader and I think we
need him in our country right now
[Music]
the Republican Party may have splintered
under the weight of change it certainly
hasn't cracked
everyone has an eye on the midterms in
November though and here they're pinning
some hope on a returning Mitt Romney and
any other establishment figure who could
help protect their conservative values
you know if I were to say one thing to
the president
let's find language that helps us in and
moves us forward rather than kind of
muddles us in conversations that really
don't help he's used an expletive to
describe other nations do you accept
that that was a racist remark and look
I've gotten an all mr. Trump I don't I
don't believe that he's racist but he
says some things that certainly make
people wonder
grabbing women in a certain area just by
retweeting anti-muslim videos
unacceptable criticizing his
administration unaccepting and yeah he's
still supported well of course I mean
there there are I don't know a single
leader that is perfect and if you find
one thing that someone says and you say
I can no longer support you because of
that then you end up supporting knowing
look he cares about Americans that feel
like they've been forgotten people in
you know in parts of our country that
have really struggled now for a
generation and one thing I become
convinced of he's actually trying to
help those people
[Music]
in the pristine corners of southern Utah
that appears to involve letting go
America is a vast in complex country and
here in the valley of the gods it feels
like you're on another planet about as
far removed from the Washington bubble
as you can imagine but Donald Trump's
reach has extended to this majestic
landscape and it's created a new heated
frontier of debate
[Music]
[Music]
this is the heart of bears ears National
Monument a million acre wilderness and
sacred site for Native Americans the
president wants to scale it back
something that could lift regulations on
grazing cattle and mining
[Music]
a pan that's pissing environmentalists
against others who want more state
control we want to see a reduction in
the monuments keep the tourists out so
you can have it yourself yeah basically
yes I think it's insane the these plans
have been collected through the years
from Theodore Roosevelt on forward to
protect for everybody to enjoy and for
some reason they might must be looking
some monetary gain or something but not
many of us are agreeing with the idea if
I were having a dinner party I would
want Barack Obama to come over he's
charming if I wanted decisions made I
would want drawn Donald Trump to make
them know I don't want to be his best
friend he's crude he's to the point but
he's I think getting things done if
Congress will let him
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Donald Trump's destiny may be defined by
how much space others are willing to
give him but one thing is for certain he
shows no sign of changing with the
seasons he is in permanent campaign mode
and however distasteful his critics may
find his outlook no one can assume now
he'll fade into the distance he may well
be in charge for another seven years
[Music]
you
[Music]